this is a production of Cornell
University initially when I was
organizing the seminar program for the
fall is very nervous about having a lot
of gaps that I wouldn't be able to fill
with speakers and happily we've we
filled them all up in fact initially my
plan was if I had to I would give one
seminar on Kesava and a second one on
Mays and you're really lucky because
they build them up and I arranged that
the seminar on cassava is going to be a
joint or shared seminar between myself
and my senior a research associate Peter
Hyde who is going to give you most of
the actual data and results from our
next gen cassava project so I'm gonna
just give you a little bit of a lead-in
and give you some context on the project
as a whole and then Peter is going to
show you most of the work on cassava
flowering that we've done in pursuit of
this project so the next-gen cassava
project is a large project funded by the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation and by
US or UK aid and we have as you can see
on this slide a number of institutions
that participate our participants in
this project the project is led and
managed by Cornell University out of
International Programs and the so Ronnie
Kaufman as the head of IP Cal's is the
principal investigator on record and the
lead project is a breeding project for
cassava and that I would say that the
lead technical lead is jean-luc Jenning
on that project so we have these other
participants who are
on the project doing breeding programs
and mainly our target is in Africa so we
have International Institute of
Agriculture in Nigeria and the national
program for cassava breeding which is
located in dk Nigeria we also have the
national programs in Uganda and in
Tanzania as participants in this project
and in this project has been underway
for approximately five years and we've
just made the transition from phase 1 to
phase 2 and phase 2 as we made sort of
gone along we've picked up contributions
from two other important places in the
world where cassava breeding is taking
place the the the International Centre
for tropical agriculture in Colombia and
the Umbra in Brazil there's also even
some participation by folks in Hawaii
for germplasm transfer from Latin
America to Africa so the project
involves quite a lot of participation by
groups throughout and we do our best to
in to become a coordinated project among
all the team members now the places that
we work correspond to the largest
production areas in Africa for cassava
and this map shows you the area
harvested in the world and you can see
that Nigeria is a lot of cassava
production in fact it is the largest
producer of cassava in the world and
Africa in general represents about 55%
of the total production of cassava so we
have our focus as to work with reading
programs in West Africa and then these
two programs Uganda and Tanzania in East
Africa there's also a lot of cassava
production particularly in Thailand and
in Indonesia Thailand has an excellent
breeding program and they are a bit more
advanced but our work is is in
coordination with programs in Africa
where we could really make some progress
improving their programs
asada has a number of tributes
so why cassava one of the reasons is
that in fact in the world the amount of
production has increased quite a lot in
recent years the trim is that the rate
of increase is somewhere between the
rate of increase in rice and in maize
production much higher than the rate of
increase in production of potatoes and
wheat and so there's have been a lot of
recognition in recent years about the
potential for cassava as being a
important prop for the future and and
producers are increasing the production
it's a highly productive crop it grows
year round so it's particularly suited
for tropical conditions where it can
bridge between the dry and wet seasons
and it can utilize the land for long
periods of time during the year and
continue to be productive it has the
right it has the reputation for being
able to tolerate stresses and in some
way be a forgiving crop for farmers that
is to say in low nutrient or mineral
nutrient conditions it can still grow
reasonably well and provide a good
production and yield it can grow and
grow prone soils and as we go to
climates in some parts of the world that
are becoming warmer it is able to
tolerate in fact it thrives in the
warmer temperature that that are
experienced so it has potential for
becoming even more important in a future
and in in that sense we could say that
it's a food security a good food
security crop it also is producing a
starchy root that has many many
different uses and so it's it's very
versatile and so once you have the
ability to produce cassava it can be
used for home use and culinary uses at
home various types of products but it
also can be used to provide a product
that can be so
for other purposes for example more
purified form of starch tapioca can be
used for a lot of different food
manufacturing uses even industrial uses
as they do in Brazil very versatile crop
there are a lot of challenges in cassava
production and that's why we need the
next gen cassava project one is the that
is not reaching full yield potential and
over the years it's been recognized as a
crop that is has a lot of breeding
obstacles difficult one of them is that
it is a crop that in order to obtain
sufficient clones that can be tested in
uniform yield trials that are replicated
at different locations it takes quite a
lot of years to build up that popular
that those numbers of propagules that
are needed in order to do that kind of
good trial and so because of that the
breeding cycle typically takes something
like eight years or more between one set
of crossing events and the next one that
would be based on phenotypic information
collected from the the first row so it's
it's rather been slow to make
improvements and because of that we feel
that there's a lot of untapped potential
and what we need is better methods of
breeding that will address the be able
to make more rapid progress accelerate
the improvement it has nutritional
limitations in that its purest starch
but it has very little vitamin mineral
content there are efforts that have been
successful in introducing higher Pro
vitamin A content and there are other
mineral new or other nutritional
characteristics that are part of the
overall strategy for self improvement
and there are some it is susceptible to
several viral and bacterial diseases
that are fairly serious threats
particularly in Africa for example in
Africa the cassava mosaic is the
CMB is a very serious problem and we
have resistance but it needs to be
incorporated into breeding lines and
cassava brown streak is a disease that
is that is expanding from the east
towards the west and currently it is it
is a serious problem in Tanzania and in
Uganda the fear is that it will spread
further into West Africa the largest
cassava producing area in the world and
will devastate production if we are not
prepared with resistance ahead of that
so that's another of the breeding
targets so the project that Grinnell
leads is a project that uses a
relatively new approach towards reading
and that's called genomic selection and
genomic selection has the potential to
accelerate sabah breeding it's a led by
and this is a diagram from a seminal
article written by Hefner mark Sorrels
and John Luciano here at Cornell and it
laid out the advantages of genomic
selection over conventional and other
breeding approaches the conventional
cassava breeding as I mentioned a little
while ago involves the clonal
propagation of of the lines and in order
to have sufficient proper yields to do a
proper accurate multi-location
replicated trials this takes a long time
and it slows down the whole advance or
improvement process genomic selection
tries to use a different strategy that
will accelerate and so what we do is we
still have the need for high-quality
phenotyping but it's done on a subset of
the population a training population and
so this training population is going to
be a subset which will represent the
breeding population as a whole and this
will be an ongoing process of improving
our knowledge
of this training set a training set that
in fact involves some changes in the
composition of the lines that are in
there what's then coupled with that is
that the training lines are genotype
using DNA analysis at markers that
expand throughout the genome and it
allows the preparation of a statistical
model for estimating the breeding value
of each individual based on the
phenotypic information in the training
cycle and the genotypic information from
the DNA analysis so then the program has
a model that will be able to predict the
potential breeding value of any
individual that is produced through
recombination and predicted based on the
model as opposed to actual field trials
of that particular line what that means
is that in the process of line
development after a cross is made and
the plants begin to grow even at the
seedling stage a very young glance
before we can have any estimate of yield
we can take an a sampling of the leaves
and do the genotypic information marker
analysis using DNA methodology use the
models predict what it's reading value
is and then make decisions on which
lines to use as parents for the next
round based on that information it can
go much more quickly and it is actually
with the low cost of sequencing it can
be cheaper actually than doing the
phenotyping the old way so the process
then involves accelerating the rate at
which this cycle goes between successive
crosses and that's recombination that's
needed and associated with that and the
problem is that cassava has another
characteristic that is an obstacle and
that is it's for flowering
characteristics and that's what Peter
and I work on that's what we're going to
tell you about today so this is an
illustration of the type of problem
this is a survey of over 1,800 clones
assessed in Abuja Nigeria new Biaggi is
the very best location for getting good
flowering in Nigeria and it is the
location that the eye ITA Institute is
using as their location from doing their
process nevertheless in Obie Asha in
this set of 1,800 lines we look at the
flowers ability and going from zero
which means no flowering at all three
which is good flowering
only around 33% or so were good
flowering the other 2/3 were either
medium or low flower in fact 15 or 18
percent were no flowering at all so what
that means is a lot of the favorable
alleles that you might wish to use in
order to improve the cassava is lar
locked up in lines that you really have
a lot of difficulty crossing and so by
finding ways to obtain better flowering
we have the potential of unlocking those
that germ plasm that could be used so
the problem is that Sabah is late
flowering takes a long time to induce
flowering maybe 4 to 9 months and some
lines not at all they will not flower
within the one year time frame flowering
among parents that you want to cross is
often not synchronous so we're just at
the mercy of whatever the flowering
behavior is and if they're non
synchronous that creates a big obstacle
to making the cross love interest we
have a low number of flowers produced so
there's one thing is the induction of
flowering the other is the quantity or
number of flowers a low percentage of
those flowers that are produced our
female flowers Peter will tell you about
that and finally there's a lot of
abortion or Arrested Development of the
flowers the fruits and the seeds in fact
each flower will potentially produce
only three seeds and oftentimes one or
several of one or all of those three
seeds do not develop because
the rest of development so the goal of
our project is to develop a set of tools
and tools that we will define as Peter
will describe the type of work that
we've been doing a set of tools that
breeders can use conveniently in their
in their nurseries the hasten flower
induction and to increase política see
in their seedling nurseries and crossing
blocks and we've been really pleased
with the very great amount of progress
that we've been able to make in
developing a set of tools and we're now
in the conclusion of phase one where we
have developed tools and we're gonna
just enter Phase two where we put more
of our emphasis on working with breeding
programs to implement them in in
practice so back to this slide here I
just shows you again the participants
and we have representatives of each of
these institutions who work with this on
the flowering program we do work under
controlled conditions like greenhouse
and growth chamber and then we depend on
them primarily to do the field studies
and Cornell Peter and I are going to be
telling you about the story Sarah a demo
just finished a pH I posted that earlier
this year and there's a little bit of
information we'll provide from her work
shangguan you may remember she finished
a master's degree about one year ago and
devorah a day is a PhD student with me
currently she's located at iit a and
working on the program as we speak so I
think that's the last of my slides and
this is where I asked the baton over to
Peter
that's not alright good
well thank you for giving me the
opportunity to share some of the work
that we've been doing I'm I find this
project really exciting she's gonna be
beneficial in the long run and it's yeah
it's gonna really fun five years I
wanted to start out by showing some
pictures and just giving a little
background on what cassava flowers are
like because I'm gonna be showing you a
lot of data and make sure that it's
understandable cassava this is a cassava
inflorescence
it starts out producing a few female
flowers these are open female flowers
and usually about ten percent of all of
the flowers are female second come the
males
these are unopened male flowers at this
point and they flower at a forking event
so the apical meristem grows and then it
branches there's two fork branches and
at that point they flower demonstration
here's our cassava field and this is
what some grow they grow up they flower
they fork they grow up again a little
bit further mmm a flower again we call
this the first tier flowering and then
this is second tier flowering generally
you get better flower development on the
second third maybe fourth tier and then
it starts to taper off but you get very
little development of flowers on the
first year sometimes they grow like this
though and you get no flower development
on any of the tiers I I say no
development it does grow at very very
small inflorescence less than a
centimeter and then of sizes and falls
off so no open flower is no possibility
of pollination
sometimes they also grow like this for a
very long time and then fork and other
times they just keep growing and growing
and growing and you get no forking no
flower development it's actually kind of
interesting too because this is a
desired trait in some areas which is
like a breeders nightmare breeding for a
trait that makes it really hard to breed
so that's something that we if we can
stimulate artificially a plant that
grows like this to flower but then it
you know in the field and growers fields
that will still be like this so this
variability is seen across genotypes and
environments so you might have one
genotype that flowers very well another
genotype is flowers very poorly you
might have a genotype that flowers very
well in one location very poorly in
another location so this is where we've
really first got started the
environmental factors and two
environmental factors that are well
known to regulate flower and influence
flower development its temperature and
photo period and other crops and these
also interact with each other so that's
where we started and now I'm gonna get
into some of this our data I'll explain
this very piece a little slower the
first time you'll see this chart many
times because this is how we represent
the age of flowering or percentage
flowering and most of our work um so
that x-axis here is age in days and the
y-axis is the percent forking this does
not mean that they produced a large
inflorescence it just means they got to
the point of forking and a lot of times
that we're happy with that at this point
and so we have three different
temperatures these were grown in growth
chambers here at Cornell and what we saw
was at a very warm temperature 34c only
about 22% actually got to the point of
forking a more moderate twenty-eight we
saw 75% forking and attic this is a very
cool temperature for cassava 22
we saw 96% for this is at the first tier
second tier we see a very similar
pattern so it really indicates the
temperature is critical to flowering or
forking we also saw that at the two
lower temperatures there was an increase
in floral development so this graph here
is a
the days after floral initiation so
after forking and then this is the
number of flowers that are present on
the inflorescence over time and so what
we see is that at 28 you get some
increase in floral development and then
at 22 you get quite a bit more floral
development and your the 34 is not on
this because those never even forked so
I can't show any data regarding the
number of flowers that were developed
another question you might have is so
are the plants just really unhealthy at
warm temperatures because 34 is pretty
warm and no actually cassava here it
grows very well at 34 vegetatively and
at 22
it is much shorter but it's a healthy
plant and you can see the forking and
flowering
the next thing we wanted to look at was
a photo period so the way we do our
photo period experiments is you have
regular grow lights for maybe ten hours
and then we do a dim light extension we
use that not photosynthetic radiation so
that they're more comparable we used red
lights red LEDs in fact because look at
this chart here this is the red the
spectrum of the red LED and it is the
max is about 640 which aligns better to
the phytochrome which is the pigment
that absorbs red light and stimulate
flowering the white LEDs you see air
shifted away from the spectrum that's
more beneficial for flowering and for
absorption by cytochrome so with the
long day extension and this is that
moderately cool temperature 25 we saw
that long days stimulates earlier
flowering you see here the at 10 hour
day it's about 40% and at a 14 hour day
we're up to about 80% and this data is
representing four different genotypes
most of the work we do we have four
different genotypes some are late
flowering or poor flowering and some are
early flowering and somewhere in the
middle so this is a means of all of
those combined men at warmer
temperatures so at 30 degrees Celsius we
see also a benefit of long day in terms
of flowering that flowering the
percentage of flowering goes up but it's
not as pronounced is that the cooler
temperature which goes along with the
fact that the first experiments we did
with temperature showing the temperature
inhibits flowering
then we also wanted to look at more
interactions between photo period and
temperature so and this was done as
opposed to a short and long day we
wanted to look at more what field grown
plants would be which would be 12 hours
and see if we just by going from 12 up
to 16 you're also seeing a benefit this
would be more what's going to happen in
the field and indeed we did so this is a
cool temperature and warm temperature at
the warm temperature of 30 or 35 day 30
night we see no flower initiation at 12
hours but with long with cool
temperatures cool temperatures at 12
hours we see some initiation of
flowering and cool temperature at long
day even better flowering so now I'm
going to step us to hide and this is a
little bit this is some work that Sarah
Eddie amo spearheaded looking at Ft
because it ties into the photo period ft
is a relatively new discovery that is
the FT gene is responsible for flower
induction and she identified 2 ft like
genes in cassava the model is that the
photo period stimulates long day
stimulates ft expression in the leaves
it's transported by the phloem to the
apical meristem or the flowering region
and stimulates flowering and this is
common in a lot of different crops and
we looked at the plants we were growing
in the photo in the different photo
periods and indeed one of the FT genes
ft2 was expressed at a higher level
under long days so it's indicating that
the ft is responsible or partially
responsible for the flowering some the
improvement in flowering that we're
seeing under long day under photo period
experiments so then conclude
for the photo period and temperature we
see that cooler temperatures hasten
flowering and warm reduce flowering long
days also decrease the time to flowering
and high temperature will reduce or
eliminate that long day effect so if you
have even with the long day if it's very
hot it will not flower and the low
wattage LEDs are effective for
stimulating flowering and this is
important when we get into field work we
wanted to have more efficient lights for
a field the next thing we were wanted to
look at was plant growth regulators and
I we don't have to study this in detail
but I put this up here because often I
explain to people that we use a few
compounds and they say well how did you
know that those particular compounds
were going to work and the fact that
matter is we had no idea we took a
shotgun approach and tested lots and
lots of plant growth regulators and we
tested them here at Cornell and then our
colleagues in Africa also worked on them
and lots of different compounds
different combinations different
concentrations and we found in the end
that there is two that are very
important to flowering cytokinins
and we're using the synthetic da and
then ethylene and we're both show work
with ethylene with STS which is silver
thiosulfate which blocks the ethylene
receptor and renders the plant
insensitive ethylene and then Etha Fon
which is a compound that's absorbed by
the plant and quickly metabolized into
ethylene
it reduces flowering
so silver thiosulfate like I said it
blocks the ethylene receptor and here's
our water control zoom in for you
there's this is what I mean by basically
no flower it's less than a centimeter
long you can see it's already turning
straw colored it's upsizing it's going
to fall off in a couple days and then
with applications spray application of
silver thiosulfate we see this enormous
in fluorescence developed so this is
really great and here's a graphical
representation of the data we saw and
this is just one concentration we tested
a few different concentrations and we
saw that with increased concentration
increased benefit so here this is water
control and then going up to 1
millimolar we got the best benefit
so that was great but it didn't work
very well in the field so we started
testing a lot of different ways to apply
us to yes we had a brainstormed a lot of
different why this wouldn't work in the
field maybe the leaves developed a
thicker waxy cuticle maybe the rain is
just washing the SPS off and it takes a
long time to be absorbed we tried some
different adjuvants we tried rain
sticker that helps the plant basically
bluesier substance choice onto the
leaves we increase the humidity of the
leaves trying to keep the stomata open
by putting bags over the tops of plants
they all some worked a little bit but
what we really found works well is this
application using petiole feeding so the
way this works is you can cut a leaf off
and then there's negative pressure
inside the plant and so if you quickly
cut the leaf off and put it into a
solution it will take up that solution
through the vascular bundles this STS is
not red this is just to explain and I
was using this as a tracer and so it is
absorbing the red liquid and then you
can see the vascular bundles if you cut
off that petiole rather quickly it a
couple hours it will be absorbed we also
cut this plant up quite a bit more and
saw that it mostly goes up in the plants
to the apical region so this is a pretty
effective way of applying s yes and we
again tested a few different
concentrations and saw that with
increased concentration up to a certain
point we see increased benefit in the
floral development okay so this this one
I need to slow down for a little bit
because it's a little complicated but
it's really exciting so what we wanted
to make sure was that STS was having
effect on ethylene and it's not just
some extraneous factor of silver being
in the plant that's causing the
flowering so we have two different
treatments over a course of time so at
first we started out by either treating
plants the water control or
with silver and these flowers were
already developed so this is unlike what
we're doing the past this is a high
flowering genotype we used flowers were
already there we sprayed them with water
or we sprayed them with STS then we
waited a little while and then of the
water controls half of them we sprayed
with SF on and half of them we did not
and of the plants that we've treated
with STS also half of them we spray -
that's a faun and half of them we did
not and if you look at this the graph
over here so we have I plan it's not
sprayed with STS and they have a decent
amount of flowers and then not spray -
that's a fine so no difference this is
our water control plants sprayed with
STS and then without s ofon again
there's no real difference STS is not
negatively influenced at flowers or
positive because these are already
developed flowers
if we don't spray with STS of water and
then we spray with F on it knocks all
those flowers off over the course this
is a about five days in between these
two treatments and then if we spray with
STS and then we spray with esif on the
SGS protects the plant from the s pathan
response and none of the flowers fall
off so this makes it pretty clear to us
that yes yes is affecting s Athan it's
or ethylene in the plant and it's an
ethylene response
so I also said we worked with cytokinin
ba again showing you a lot of these
controls no no flowers but and we saw
that bi had a slight beneficial effect
on flowering alone but it was it was not
as good as s yes so initially we weren't
that excited about it but we we kept
being intrigued
but then what we saw was that the
combination of STS and BA there's a
synergistic effect and we get these very
large inflorescences developed this is
really exciting we're better than the
SDS so this is this looks really great
for us
and here is a graphical representation
you can see that the water control and
then we have STS alone VA alone but then
with the combination multiplicative
effect and it's it's much greater than
the sum of the two so that was by was
wonderful but it gets better I can't
believe it Kenya so who would go back to
this picture of I showed you before and
what I'm gonna point out to you is like
I said earlier typical flowering you get
a few females here you can see this is
actually fruit developing and then males
up at the top zoom in oh I went ahead
what we see is that with us guess alone
you get males on the top this is a
typical ratio but with BA it's all
females the entire inflorescence is
females so we have about 150 female
flowers on this for a breeder who's
trying to get seed this is actually very
very useful data it goes along with this
that we can see hey we get a slight
increase of ba and STS but then with the
two almost 100% females we wanted to
look more into this and when when do we
need to apply this ba to get this shift
and what we did here was we have control
and then the STS and Oba and then VA 14
days before any visible flowering at
flowering and then 14 days after and
what we see is you really have to get
that application to be a on before you
can even see any flowering so it
indicates that the transition to females
is happens very early in floral
development but you actually do see a
benefit in floral development applying
the at flowering or a little bit after
flowering but it just you don't get the
massive shift to mostly females
so in conclusion for our plant growth
regulators we see that foliar
applications of SDS can increase the
quantity of flowers STS protects the
flower from ethylene applying through
the petiole is effective
combination of bas GS is much more
effective and that BA increases the
percentage of female flowers
one of the last topics I'm going to
touch on is pruning so pruning is people
have done this a lot where you can
manipulate source ink relationships and
plants by by removing parts by cutting
them off our colleague in Colombia
Hernan Ceballos started doing a little
work on this and we he mentioned it to
us and we carried on with it also and
what we do is when the plant is very
young so earlier than this stage and
these lateral fork branches are less
than a half a centimeter long so very
small there's three branches usually and
then inflorescence is also less than a
half a centimeter long you cut those
branches off so you get in there with a
magnifying glass and scalpel them pop
them off and then you get a nice
inflorescence develops this was really
cool so no plant growth regulator is
needed and you get a huge inflorescence
at the first year which the first year
normally doesn't produce many flowers
even in a high flowering genotype and so
this can really push the time to get
flowers and to get seed quite a bit
faster
a breeding nursery we decided to take it
one step further and see if ba would
have the same feminization effect as we
saw with the sts and it sure does you
get about a hundred percent females so
here's the data I'm showing that you get
a increase with both pruning and pruning
NBA
so the next phase as Tim mentioned is
going to be we've kind of developed a
tool box and trying to disseminate this
information out to breeders we've been
doing some trips and trying to develop
red light setups so we can stimulate
basically mimic long days in the field
using LEDs is really nice because
they're low-energy
and these will probably be set up on
solar systems solar powered so they can
be put in any field working with people
like Simon Peter here to do some PGR
applications in the field and working
with the folks like Smith who are
actually he leads all the crossing at
IIT a for the most part so not so much
with the breeders both the people that
are actually doing the work doing the
crossing how can they best utilize this
information and benefit their there
crossing the best
so in conclusion just a few things we
saw that long day is beneficial cool
temperatures around 25 or the seem to be
the best that's kind of difficult to
manipulate in the field SPS ba are great
for improving flowering and pruning also
works some of the challenges are this
the STS in the field we haven't seen as
good of benefit as we have seen in the
greenhouse so trying to work on that and
then for phase 2 really optimizing these
methods for the field developing the
best applications for them assessing
fruit and seed set in the field as
they're doing the pollination making
sure this these methods work with
crossing the developing field scale
photo period extension field testing of
the pruning best combinations because
there's a lot of different combinations
you can do probably doing some of the
photo period extension with the PD ours
will have I'm guessing that's where
we'll probably end up going and doing
workshops that training people how to
use these this technology so thank you
all for paying attention and I hope this
I find this really exciting hope you do
too
and I'd like to thank our partners and
our donors wouldn't be possible so
[Applause]
any questions I agree very exciting even
so my question is maybe a procedure but
Tim additionally talking about using
phenotyping of a training set to kind of
predict certain properties and related
to genotypic information and then your
later on you're manipulating the feed on
typical features is that an issue in in
terms of the broader program where you
do the phenotype much earlier on so the
phenotyping on the training set is a set
of coins representative of the breeding
population at large and it's done
without making any crosses the breeding
program requires the crossing in order
to get recombination and favourable
alleles brought in together so that is
done on this right hand half of that
diagram where you would wish to do that
cycling as quickly as possible and the
genome tipic r GS scientific selection
allows you to have a model that's
developed to relate the performance
let's say the yield and the markers that
are marking and sampling a genome the
sequence that's a single nucleotide
position be able to model that and then
from the the progeny that are produced
at each turn of the cycle you're going
to do several thousand lines analyze
them by DNA analysis and then from that
DNA information you will be able to
predict what their breeding values are
whether they would be good parents to
select in
the next round of crossing so we're
we're what we're needed for is to help
take young plants and get them to flower
as quickly as possible and in numbers of
flowers as many as possible so that when
they have selected desirable parents
they can make the desired crosses on a
timely schedule and in fact in some
cases there are lines that they would
like to use but they don't flower at all
under conventional conditions I don't
know I hope that helps I understand that
different ages of the whole program we
get the question a lot well aren't you
going to harm the farmers yield
potential no we're only working in the
nursery with these tools this is a
Breeders toolbox the farmers will not
have an altered flowering plant if all
goes unless the breeding selection
resulted in in fact in our case it's
likely that we would be selecting for
low flowering lines more so than under
conventional conditions so it won't
affect what the farmer will have as a
I'll take that question and the question
is whether there has been enough
information collected to evaluate
whether the process of genomic selection
and the model development is effective
we did not talk about that part of the
story and in fact there have been a
series of seminars primarily in the lamp
reading seminar program where jean-luc
and shadows e GC and others and several
students of PhD students have gone
through the program and have also
presented but the answer to your
question is that yes there's evidence
that it is working is it a two-fold
10-fold no it's not that kind of thing
it's a quantitative trait reading a
breeding for yield which is one of the
primary targets is a process that is
going to result in steady but relatively
small improvements over time you're
talking one to ten percent one to five
percent increase per cycle it's so it is
working and so we're encouraged to go to
this phase two which we're just entering
now variation in terms of flowering
between different cassava lines so your
date that implied that if we have this
creation is due to endogenous like high
clobbering lines have low and highly
excited so have you murdered have you
done
[Music]
show that you know planet that we're not
treating does ethylene know know what
they want so in the lines of high
flowering potential but wait a bit of
variation in terms of how much hours are
produced so what they wonder whether
this variation between lines can be also
do for this inherent ability of this
line to produce for example those line
which consistently produce lots of
flowers they actually produce less like
there was like initially yes that's a
very good point and we haven't measured
ethylene production across genotypes
this point but it should perceive the
could not be that what little we have
down and this was when Shangguan was a
master's student and she tried a few
different lines there wasn't that
particular factor the ethylene was not
the key differentiating property so I'd
say that's not terribly surprising
because you have really in in the
process of signaling for both flower
induction and for flower set quite a lot
of different things that could be
genetically different between lines and
so that at least in the lines that she
surveyed very small 419 and triple 0 to
that wasn't the key thing similarly when
we look at the FT production while the
genotypic I mean they've been a photo
period excuse me photo period difference
in the FT to transcript levels was
showing very clear relationship to photo
period if we look at the genotype
differences that transcript abundance
alone wasn't a good predictor so clearly
there's many other components of a
signal
pathway that could be different between
lines that could be responsible for the
overall outcome it hasn't been our
objective to do a complete and thorough
investigation of what causes these
things we've been very much in the
applied science mode where we're looking
for this toolbox things that will work
for the readers sadly as a physiologist
we have not been given the
responsibility to pursue molecular
physiology
would be formally propagated crop and
once it's released as a clone then it
will stay the same
well it should say the same it has pros
and cons I mean you do fix the genotype
by your cloning because it's clonally
propagated crop that can be an advantage
once you have created something that's
valuable it stays it can be propagated
and kept the same over many many years
in many locations it does have the
obstacles in the breeding process what I
would consider challenges well yes but
that's part of the conventional
agriculture in a clone we propagated
from in the case of cassava what it
entailed there is this issue of once a
breeding program has developed something
superior and they're ready to release it
then there needs to be a propagation
process at IIT a they've been
experimenting they have a nice method
for doing this in a kind of semi tissue
culture it's more explant culture under
aseptic conditions and then when I was
there for example they had thousands of
little boxes sort of plexiglass they
would ship it out to Catholic Charities
and then Catholic Charities in turn
would plant them out where the plants
would be grown for one cycle and you get
a process going where you can quickly
amplify or propagate to large scale for
a release similar things have to happen
in any breeding program where you go
from initial small little hand
full of seed - you want to have now
thousands of bushels if you read the
story about Norman Borlaug taking
releasing lines in India you know that's
a really big part of the whole process
and then cassava it's especially
challenging because it is it's
vegetative propagation but it is it's
doable and it just requires some you
know have some resources let's say the
voters without but there is the
advantage that once it's released then
it can be shared with neighbors and it's
always identical and it can be
disseminated and spread if it's a it's
unacceptable and highly desirable
question you mentioned in your kind of
future vision that you were planning on
saying red light with PG are together if
you've done any initial Studies on that
and is it synergistic small studies and
shown that I wouldn't say it's
synergistic but they do work together
well especially what you said the red
light and the like yes yes those are
kind of two different factors because
one is dealing with the timing of
flowering and one is dealing with
flowering abundance and we did want to
make sure that you know it still works
under the red lights and it does but we
didn't identify really a synergistic
effect that is the sort of thing that
for example turned on Sebelius at SIA is
actively working on as well as our
colleagues
we'd like to see that kind of work done
you know sort of taken out this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at Cornell edu